okay Sarah good morning good morning
after watching JD try to use the lighter
on the app I was wondering if he's ever
tried to put in contact why do you say
that I was clipping my nails this
weekend and I was wondering if JD can
clip his own nails because if he doesn't
have the dexterity to light a lighter
how could he use a nail clipper and
Clippers on nails JD is a waste of two
thumbs yet JD can you work a nail
clipper
JD can you work a nail clipper yes I can
work a nail clipper I cut my nails this
weekend what about you don't wear
contacts do you I did in high school but
not anymore
and you were able to put him in uh yeah
I wonder Reid I hate it
put it taking them off and putting them
in so that's one reason I just would
staple classes can you tie your own
shoes did you have to make like the baby
like way of doing it or can you do it
with a single loop a single loop I don't
know what other words there's two ways
of tying your shoes when you're a little
kid they first teach you to make two
loops and then tie together but then
when you become a little more grown-up
you make one loop and then you wrap the
thing around it and then you don't I'm
saying I mean I make two loops I go
under it he does the baby way up you
don't know the adult way right what is
he wearing a bowtie for today he's part
of the high pitch Harith way and he'll
be actually putting the books on the
scale Eric looks handsome today looks
good thank you like my boy
maybe the bowtie is his luck can you
light a match like from a matchbook I
think so yeah I don't I haven't really
done it but you couldn't I'll try but I
don't said anything I don't I mean like
those paper matches in the little books
yeah I don't think he can do it we
should do a game what can JD do well
let's look up all the things you need
your thumb for cuz he can't tie his
shoes like a grown-up can you snap your
fingers nice crisp sound yeah hey Wolfie
what's up a couple things first of all
could you ask 80 about the way that he
ties his shoes because when I observed
in that
he did something really weird he touched
the loops into the side of the shoes
next to his ankles I've never seen that
that was when laces of my shoes were too
long and I was stepping on them and I
don't have that anymore
why don't you double knot it I don't
like the double knot you want me to
teach you the grown-up way - I'm being
serious so I'll teach you today I'm fine
can you tie a tie no I do not in a hat i
hmm hey JD could you split a piece of
firewood with an axe probably not now
could you uh did you drive a nail into a
board using a hammer he's ignoring you
hey what you said what I can't listen
and chew gum at the same time